let's go to our next caller what about
the 845 area code caller from 845 go
ahead hey this is Mark Benjamin go ahead
mark I'd like to continue with that
statistics question I had long before
but I have a couple of others as well
well let's stick what's your best or
most important question for today that
you would like asked to ask something on
Jordan Peterson okay actually go ahead
there's um someone that makes his points
just relatively better much in a much
more clear fashion and that doesn't have
a an over ton of bias Jonathan Hyde or
Hyatt yeah baby says it yeah and he goes
into group mentality and basically like
I said just a more clean-burning of what
what Jordan Peterson does okay I just
had it better better and I'd like to
your thoughts on his his view on
liberals conservatives and libertarians
as he points out are kind of different
and not a special way just in
temperament so I'm not talking about
policy I'm talking about temperance when
you say and King are you talking about
Jordan Peterson or Jonathan hate right
now Jonathan Hyde okay I don't know
anything about his views unfortunately I
don't know anything about his views on
on that so I wouldn't I wouldn't be able
to say how unfortunate
yeah well as for the statistics one
after you know after you're done talking
with me I was on late earlier in the
month I asked what's the best way to
gather information to you know sell for
self-taught learning on mine because I
don't really have the resources to go to
college and do all this mmm the ground
work and you pointed me out to a
statistics book and you're also about to
say something and then of course I hung
up before then by accident
okay I don't remember what I was about
to say what I can tell you is that at
this point between websites like Khan
Academy class central I mean there's
just so many so many you know Coursera
just start doing free online classes and
statistics if you're if you're looking
to learn statistics there's a wealth of
free resources mark and I would
definitely encourage you to check those
out